it seems riot Kari was closer to walk
you down the aisle than any of us ever
knew everything was already in place
almost everything now we're hearing me
me and her billionaire fiance may have
been fighting over a freedom rock
I just need to know that everything is
not gonna be a piece of a 100-page
prenup that Mariah never signed and
that's why she's keeping the ring plus
demanding a 50 million dollar settlement
that's just the beginning of all the new
reports that have surfaced today
mid-february is when the couple was
allegedly trying to hammer out the
specifics one prenup condition
reportedly stated if they divorced
Mariah got that huge payout also in case
of a split any jewelry James gave the
singer had to be given back unless he
gave her a signed note saying it was a
gift so does that mean that so-called
ten million dollar engagement ring came
with just that kind of note you know
what
you never know from one day to the night
is gonna bring right now to be prepared
March first was apparently the original
wedding date mariah is said to have had
the dress the flowers and all the travel
for guests was booked the problem
besides the unsigned prenup Mariah's ex
Nick Cannon still hadn't signed their
divorce papers by that time our sources
tell us Mariah was actually blindsided
when news broke last Thursday of their
split she originally wanted to release a
joint statement and keep things amicable
with the billionaire right now Mimi and
the kids are staying here in this 250
thousand dollar-a-month mansion she once
shared with James but the singer was
forced to live here at the Beverly Hills
Hotel for a few weeks
my life has not been a fairytale can I
focus on the important things
so then what caused this couple to
crumble are moriah source claims this
man is partly to blame
Packers business manager Tommy Davis who
quote felt like he couldn't control
Mariah who's not to blame
we're told the breakup had nothing to do
with Mariah's manager Stella B'Elanna
cough in fact our cameras caught Stella
with James both taking care of Mariah
together when they were all in Paris and
it also had nothing to do with backup
dancer Bryan Tanaka they're not dating
they've always just been close friends
quote she is not into him in that way
but he's fun and great company
you